okay last question today and this is
from many people so I'm not even citing
a particular person people want to know
can producer Pat explain what vegan
Thanksgiving is like because a lot of
Thanksgiving staples are either they
contain meat or they're vegetarian but
not vegan like for example sour cream
horseradish chive mashed potatoes sour
cream is not vegan etc so horseradish
vegan horse rat yeah it's not really
from a horse oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
clever that's a good one I don't know if
pat was genuinely asking or just being
funny which is why it's perfect
tell us a little bit about what happens
at vegan Thanksgiving in turn let's let
me walk us through first of all what are
items that sometimes are made available
for vegan Thanksgiving well you're gonna
want to have your staple food that
centers the whole meal around sure right
I mean for most people that's a turkey
absolutely you have a number of options
you can do like a shepherd's pie for
example with like lentils and potatoes
in it you could do maybe like a tempeh
stew okay you know there are a number of
stuffed squash that's another one maybe
step what it like spaghetti squash sure
yeah you do that
sure okay so these are things that you
could do right but where where you go
for Thanksgiving how widely known is it
is it very widespread now that you are
coming as a vegan do you let people know
do you just figure oh I'll figure out
something to eat after or before that's
why I come with my Tupperware containers
although my family is very accommodating
are they really yeah and you know many
of the side dishes like you pointed out
mashed potatoes for example you can just
make them vegan sure you just do like
Sai butter and milk alternative right
yeah yeah you could do that what about
I'm trying to think what other dishes I
mean I guess sweet marries a toss I mean
there's so many things are already vegan
like the vegetables that you'll have
there well cranberry sauce sometimes has
gelatin that's true yeah and I don't
know if it's still common that it's not
that it's horse hoof or cow hoof or now
do cows of hooves yeah they have
something and then or if now they're
using like a like a vegan alternative to
that so what will you bring this time
in your toppers I'm going with the
shepherd's pie you're making sure yeah
the APRA mention shepherd's pie and
you'll be doing is it'll be lentil based
or kind of like a fake ground meat
because there's these fake needs that
our tofu generate I try to get away from
those as much as I can
really I mean generally a lazy cook but
I think Thanksgiving is the time that
you have to go all out oh yeah
absolutely
Pat's been cooking for weeks actually
you know there's still the family
there's still the conversation there of
course football - you know the pigskin
football yes of course do you insist on
a vegan football your any games that
will be watched on Thanksgiving yep you
do all right and then lastly what about
dessert because I'm trying to think
pie with ice cream is common you can of
course skip the ice cream but all the
pies have butter right I didn't even
think about this honestly yeah he's
gonna have a strictly fruit yeah I don't
know will you've said that at
restaurants you don't ask whether
they're cooking with butter will you ask
if the pie has butter I mean it's pretty
obvious any flaky I has but I is not
gonna be something I can eat it's not
going to guarantee that yeah all right
it's a bit of a shame well I'm kind of
I'm depressed I'm not gonna lie because
it sounds like it's gonna be a tough
Thanksgiving food-wise am i doing a poor
job in marketing
supposed to be inspiring people to join
the cause yeah if anybody has been moved
to veganism by Pat's description of his
of his lunch tomorrow then please email
in I didn't even get to the gravy - oh
well gravy is uh right well great I mean
everywhere I go now I don't really know
anybody else doing pork gravy all the
gravies that I'm familiar with are
usually beef broth or chicken broth but
they do have cream so even if you did
veggie broth and and made a gravy from
that usually you would still have cream
in it yeah you would uh which would be a
problem and would not be vegan so many
would like turkey No Oh turkeys horrible
okay no no I mean listen so dry meat
it's very dry turkey is very dry I don't
really like the dark meat so my move is
usually I'll get a few slices of the of
the white meat turkey and then I'll get
the non pork base this is an insane
segment the non pork based gravy and
I'll put that over there and then I will
also get the pork free because I go I go
to Merrill friends families play
and they don't eat pork either which is
great they do a pork free stuffing
because sometimes the stuffing has like
bits of of pork I don't know exactly out
what it is pancetta right I'm not sure
what's in there the stuffing thing gives
me the chills
you know chills right stuffing the
turkey I don't want to oh yeah but I I
actually they don't actually stuff it
out of there most most people just cook
the the stuffing separately and then you
kind of like put it on top it's all new
to me yeah Pat's been out of the game
for so long that he doesn't know how
that works okay that's it oh by the way
is a tempeh stew a type of soup do you
want to add on to that controversy an
hour it's not primarily liquid it's a
stew so it's definitely not a soup yeah
okay so have a great Thanksgiving and we
will we will be back we will be back on
Monday and it'll be an incredible day